looks like we got another wb animated dc
movie batman soul of the dragon
exclusive trailer michael j
white mark dakoskas no cool two dudes i
like to see fight in real life
nice pad richard you haven't changed
you might be surprised
[Music]
is this like a different era it's the
70s
it's a way to keep my lives separate i
can't think of the last time i saw each
other i bet you can remember the last
time
the first time too
oh no way yeah he's back they all say
that
ben turner that must be michael j white
[Music]
i assume you're in some kind of trouble
no matter how much
lots of flute music and all that this
isn't going to be easy
remember you are stronger together
i was not expecting this
oh my goodness i hope that's on hbo max
it ought to be that's a delight i love
these elseworlds approach that the
i mean like comic books take but
especially when the animated movies go
out of their way
to do that whether it be like batman
ninja or
uh what's that one called the gotham by
gaslight one
yeah yeah whenever they decide to go
into like different eras do these
reimaginings and to do something that's
like monkey fresh
70s flare that kind of reminds me of
like enter the dragon
or any one of those exploitation films
from the 70s i think is actually kind of
fitting for batman i don't know how fans
are actually responding to this one i
don't know if
they'll like this approach to it if it
seems a little too
goofy or silly and especially if like
going into this i didn't know anything
about it but if you told me oh bruce tim
from batman the animated series is
working on this
i would have gone in expecting something
significantly more
heavy weighty and serious and then to
get something
that feels so fun what's kind of a
pleasant surprise for me
sometimes they don't quite hit the mark
when they're going for just fun
as it stands i mean i think it looks
cool i don't it doesn't look great
i feel like the trailers for a lot of
these dc animated movies don't
really properly represent the greatness
that is
so many of these movies even the ones
that i love and i've seen plenty of them
i rarely love the trailer themselves and
then here
i feel like it could be a similar
situation where like i don't know why
the marketing is never that great for
them
but i actually like the idea of seeing
batman in the 70s yeah i do too
i mean this looks like yeah a fantasy of
sorts it's kind of like what if you got
batman and bruce lee kareem abdul-jabbar
and like maybe yeah
70s martial arts exploitation movie and
yeah there is probably a lot that's hard
to maybe
throw all the way out there in the
trailer and coming from bruce tim i
guess what i would then expect is that
this movie will probably be very fun but
hopefully we'll have that weight that
you expect from his approach to batman
storytelling but
yeah just as like an else world's
getting to see bruce wayne in a
different era
behaving you know kind of according to
that era and then seeing yeah this
ensemble mission come together looks
like
a lot of fun yeah and to return to that
animation style too and see it updated
like it's pretty exciting the music is
great in here yeah and what i'm hoping
for that this trailer doesn't really
quite give me because they're focusing
more on the kung fu
angle of it all than going to that area
and of course the other characters it
really feels
mainly entered the dragon inspired to me
seeing what like the wayne manor bruce
wayne batcave
lifestyle is all like i mean yeah you
see the sideburns you see that richard
it looks like bruce lee
yeah you know i want to see a little bit
more of that flare in here because it
might as well go all out if you're going
to be in the 70s but as it stands this
bat exploitation movie looks awesome
guys
what do you think leave your thoughts
down below i think it's gonna be a blast
subscribe hit that notification bell
click the like button
catch you guys soon thanks for being
[Music]
here